in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion from a 16th, on which we commemorate our righteous father,
Theodore, the sanctified.
On the 16th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our venerable father, Theodore,
the sanctified, disciple of St. Pocomios.
Born into a noble Christian family in Upper Egypt, St. Theodore led a devout life from his
childhood.
At the age of 12, looking at a festive meal prepared by his family for the feast of the
Theophony, he was pierced with compunction and said,
If you enjoy all this food, you will not enter eternal life.
From that time on, he fasted every day until the evening and completely abstained from
all delicacies.
Two years later, he was received into the monastery of Latopolis, where he had led the
ascetic life under some elderly monks.
Then, hearing the wisdom of Pocomios praised, he went with burning desire to tabernisi.
From the time he arrived at the monastery, Theodore set himself to imitate, in all ways
our Holy Father, Pocomios, whom he regarded as the visible presence of God.
He was vigilant in keeping his heart rigorously pure, in employing a measured and pleasant
speech and in practicing unconditional obedience unto death.
His admirable progress in the Holy Virtues allowed him to become, despite his youth, the
comfort and model of many of the brethren.
In the first year of his monastic life, as he got up one day to pray, his cell was suddenly
illumined and two radiant angels appeared to him.
Terrified, Theodore rushed out of the door and climbed onto the roof, but the angels came
to reassure him and symbolically handed him a large number of keys.
On another occasion, his mother came to visit him, but Theodore refused to see her, for
fear of having to reproach himself on the day of judgment, for having transgress the commandment
which prescribes a permanent renunciation of kin to those who wish to be perfect.
And he said, I have no mother and nothing in this world, for it is transitory.
When Saint Pocomios reprimanded him in order to test him, Theodore did not try to justify
himself, but attributed the fault to himself, and then said, I must weep until the Lord
sets my heart a right again, and I am worthy to obey his commands.
One day, a brother who had been reprimanded by Saint Pocomios was preparing to leave the
monastery.
Theodore went to him, and, pretending to have made a similar resolution, was able to revive
the brother's courage and save him from perdition.
Another time, having questioned an elderly monk and found him incapable of renouncing his
attachment to his family, he pretended to wish to leave such a monastery in which so little
notice was taken of the words of the gospel, and, by this ruse, was able to correct him.
One Sunday evening, when he was thirty years old, Saint Pocomios, having gathered the brethren
together for his regular catechises, suddenly stopped speaking, and handed the word over to Theodore.
Theodore, obediently began to speak, saying whatever the Lord had inspired him to say.
While Saint Pocomios stood among the other brethren, listening to him.
Some of the elders were irritated by this elevation of a younger monk, and left the assembly.
At the end of the synaxes, Pocomios declared that they had made themselves strangers to
God's mercy, and that, if they did not repent of this movement of pride, it would be difficult
for them to obtain eternal life.
After this, circa 336, he appointed Theodore, steward of the monastery at Tabernisi, and made
him his assistant in the administration of the Kino Nia.
Having been tested in humility and stripped of all self-will, there was no change in Theodore's
attitude, and he continued as a faithful disciple to edify the brethren, his words being filled
with grace and charity, covering all their weaknesses.
Every day, after his work, he would go to Fobo to listen to Pocomios' catechises, he then
returned to Tabernisi, and repeated it to his monks.
Having been ordered by St. Pocomios to visit the monasteries of the Kino Nia, he was always
welcomed with great joy by the brethren, for God had given him the charisma of consolation,
and Pocomios was wont to say of him.
Theodore and I accomplished the same service for God's honor, and he has the authority to
command as a father and teacher.
Because of this, he removed him after some time from Tabernisi in order to involve him in
the spiritual guidance of the whole congregation.
It was Theodore who received the new monks into the monasteries, and who sent away the recalcitrants.
When he corrected a brother, he would undertake to accomplish the same penance, fearing to
be condemned by God for not having accomplished himself what he ordained for others.
On one occasion when Pocomios was ill, the brethren sought out Theodore to ask him to become
Pocomios' successor should their father die.
When Pocomios recovered, he asked each brother for an account of his thoughts.
Theodore confessed that, under the pressure exerted by the brethren, he had acquiesced
in their proposition to succeed him.
Then Pocomios took away from him all authority over the monks, and banished him to a solitary
place, where he shed copious tears for his sin of pride.
After years of penitence, and only a short time before Pocomios' death, the latter re-established
him in his former position, declaring to the brethren that this trial had made Theodore
progress seven times more than all his former eschesees, because of the humble repentance he
had shown.
After St. Pocomios' death in 346, Theodore, who buried him in a secret place, was sent
to Alexandria on business.
He visited St. Anthony the Great, who testified to his admiration for Pocomios and the
Sanabitic life, and who sent him to St. Athanasius with a letter of recommendation.
It was while he was in Alexandria that he learned of Petronius' death, and returning to the
bayed, submitted with humility and fervor to St. Orciusius.
He was like a sheep before him, having torn out from his heart all desire for power.
Even though in the eyes of many, he was the most worthy to succeed St. Pocomios.
Seeing that many of the brethren had recourse to him and wishing to avoid all rivalry, he
managed to have himself sent to the monastery of Pagnum, to direct the bakery there.
When Apoloneus, the superior of the monastery of Moncosis, Thmusons, rebelled, desiring to make
his monastery independent, Orciusius stood down and designated Theodore to succeed him
as the head of the Quinoña.
Theodore immediately gathered together the brethren and exhorted them with tears to maintain
the tradition instituted by St. Pocomios, and to preserve the unity of their holy assembly.
He then carefully visited each of the monasteries, changed the superiors, and redistributed the
offices, remembering the penance imposed on him by St. Pocomios for his thoughts regarding
the succession.
He did not, however, regard himself as the superior of the monasteries, but only as the
one who replaced Orciusius as his servant.
And whenever he had to take a decision, he would go first, he would go first, to Kenoboskyon,
to which Orciusius had retired, to ask for his authorization.
He was a model of humility among the brethren, in dress, in his words, and in his entire
conduct.
In spite of his reputation that had spread through the whole of Egypt, and of the numerous
healing he had accomplished, thanks to his diligence, he succeeded in restoring good
order to the Quinoña, and in reviving the zeal of the monks.
He spoke with each one, exhorting them courageously to resist the assault of the thoughts, and
corrected negligence with patience, praying ardently for their reform.
To the monasteries founded by St. Pocomios, he added those of Cuior and Oui, in the region
of Hermopolis, and another near Hermonthes, as well as two women's monasteries.
In about 363 St. Athanasius, while in exile visited the Quinoña, where he admired its order
and rule, that were helpful in procuring peace for many souls, Theodore said to him,
God's favor comes to us thanks to our Father Pocomios, yet, when we see you, it is as
Christ that we see you.
After this Theodore succeeded in persuading Oricius to return to Favol, and to serve as
his assistant, and they took it in turns to visit the monasteries.
The material preoccupations of the monasteries had grown considerably because of the increased
number of brethren, and Theodore was grieved to see the monks abandoning the rigor and
simplicity of the life instituted by St. Pocomios.
He would mortify himself so that they should do penance, and would pass long nights in prayer
at the tomb of St. Pocomios, unknown to all but himself.
After Easter, in 368, Theodore fell ill.
Oricius begged the Lord to let him be the first to die and to leave Theodore of whom the
Quinoña had such great need, but such was not God's will, and, after having confessed that
he had done nothing without obedience, Theodore fell asleep very peacefully on the 27th of April.
All the brethren uttered great cries and wailed.
We are orphans, for it is our righteous father Pocomios who has died today in his person.
After the funeral, St. Oricius went to place his body beside the secret tomb of St. Pocomios.
As soon as he learned of the news, St. Athanasius wrote to the brethren telling them that Theodore
had not ceased to be among them since he formed a single person with Abba Oricius, and exhorting
them not to lament for one who was henceforth forever in the dwelling place of the blessed.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.